digamos que tenemos la ecuación 7x igual
a 14 ok
7 por equis es igual a 14 ahora antes de
tratar de resolver esta ecuación
yo quiero que pensemos un poco acerca de
lo que esto significa que tal cual lo
que esta ecuación dice es que 7 veces x
es igual a 14 claver 7
a veces
la equis la ponemos en rosa es igual a
14 ahora estoy segura de que tú podrías
resolver esta ecuación en tu cabeza muy
rápidamente es súper natural tratar de
sustituir el x por números sencillos y
ver si eso funciona o sea por ejemplo
podríamos ver si funciona cuando x es
igual a 1 y entonces vemos y 7 veces 11
que es lo mismo que 7 por 1 es igual a
14 pues con el 1 no funciona entonces
vamos con el siguiente número más
sencillo o sea vamos con un 2 y vemos 7
veces 2 o sea 7 por 2 7 por 2 es igual a
14 entonces aquí está x de aquí podemos
decir rápidamente que es un 2 y hay
muchas ecuaciones que son así de
sencillas y que se pueden resolver de
esta forma sin embargo lo que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo es tratar de
resolver estas ecuaciones de una forma
sistemática para que cuando veas una
ecuación mucho más complicada que sea
muy
muy difícil de resolver de esta forma
entonces sepas muy bien cómo resolverla
ok porque si hay ecuaciones muy
complicadas que estén en chinas de
resolver de esta forma y estoy seguro
que eventualmente te vas a encontrar con
algunas de ellas de hecho con muchas de
ellas entonces es muy importante que
aprendas a manipular las ecuaciones a
transformarla pero también es súper
importante que sepas exactamente qué es
lo que nos quieren decir qué es lo que
significan todos estos símbolos y tal
vez debería describir un por 7 por equis
ahora porque no estoy poniendo el
símbolo de x o algo por el estilo como
lo hacíamos en aritmética pues porque
ahora estamos en álgebra y en álgebra ya
no ponemos ese símbolo en álgebra
tenemos estas variables y la variable
más común es una equis que es demasiado
parecido al símbolo de x ok
esta ecuación tal cual lo que significa
es
por x es igual a 14 pero este símbolo
resulta ser muy confuso porque se parece
demasiado a la equis o sea aquí podría
alguien pensar que estoy poniendo 7 x x
o podrían pensar que estoy poniendo 7 x
x y no saben por qué estoy multiplicando
entonces para el álgebra este símbolo
más que ayudarnos nos estorba ahora hay
otro símbolo para denotar que estamos
multiplicando estas dos cosas que
también se usa a veces que es
simplemente un puntito que ponemos aquí
7 nuestro puntito de x x igual a 14
estas 3 ecuaciones son la misma cosa
exactamente pero como que en general no
se usa en álgebra en general simplemente
ponemos 7x igual a 14 y todo el mundo
sabe que eso significa que este 7 está
multiplicando a esta variable
ahora para aprender cómo manipular estas
ecuaciones lo primero que vamos a hacer
es visualizar qué es lo que quiere decir
esta ecuación así es que voy a
reescribir esta ecuación pero de una
forma más visual ok a ver aquí tenemos
7x o sea 7 por equis y lo que nos dice
la definición de multiplicación es que
si tenemos 7 por equis lo que realmente
tenemos es x
x + x
x o sea estamos sumando 7 veces x eso es
simplemente la definición de
multiplicación entonces x mas x + x mas
x mas x mas x haber 123456
7 y de este lado tenemos que esta suma
de 7x o sea 7 por x es igual a 14 ahora
este 14 también lo queremos en su forma
visual entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
poner 14 cosas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 bien ok entonces estas dos
ecuaciones nos dicen exactamente lo
mismo son equivalentes ahora la razón
por la que escribí esta ecuación por acá
es para que entiendas perfectamente qué
es lo que vamos a estar haciendo cuando
dividamos entre 7 en haber entonces
siempre que tenemos una ecuación de esta
forma donde tenemos un número que está
multiplicando nuestra variable
generalmente a este número se le llama
coeficiente pero bueno el chiste es que
tenemos un número multiplicando a la
variable
a otro número para encontrar a equis o
sea para resolver esta ecuación ya nada
más nos falta un solo paso ok y ese paso
es dividir de los dos lados del igual
entre el coeficiente de nuestra variable
o sea entre 7 en este caso porque
entonces dividimos del lado izquierdo
entre 7 y entonces a fuerzas tenemos que
dividir del lado derecho entre 7 también
porque hay por que este signo de igual
lo que nos dice es que esta cosa es
igual a esta otra cosa y si queremos
preservar este signo de igual si
queremos que el lado izquierdo siga
siendo igual al lado derecho entonces
todo lo que le hagamos al lado izquierdo
se lo tenemos que hacer al lado derecho
también entonces si queremos dividir a 7
x entre 7 tenemos a fuerzas que dividir
a 14 entre 7 para que esto siga siendo
igual a esto entonces lo que queremos es
encontrar a x
y aquí x está multiplicándose por 7 pero
luego dividiéndose entre 7 y pues eso es
simplemente igual a x porque multiplicar
por siete y luego dividir entre 7 es
como no hacerle nada a esta x entonces
este 7 se cancela con este 7 y nos queda
que x es igual a 14 entre 7 pero 14
entre 7 es igual a 2
ahora para entender exactamente qué es
lo que estamos haciendo en el fondo
cuando dividimos de los dos lados del
igual entre 7 pues vamos a dividir
visualmente los dos lados de esta
ecuación entre 7 aunque recuerda que
esta ecuación es equivalente a esta
ecuación nada más lo estamos escribiendo
de una forma más visual y bueno también
vamos a hacer esta división entre 7 de
una forma más visual kei dividir este
lado del igual entre 7 es exactamente
igual a dividirlo en siete pedazos
iguales
ok este es el primer pedazo segundo
pedazo tercer pedazo cuatro pedazos
cinco pedazos seis pedazos y siete
pedazos y además son todos igualitos
ahora otra vez si dividimos entre siete
de un lado del igual también tenemos que
hacerlo del otro lado del igual para que
sigan siendo iguales
entonces aquí vamos a dividir esto en
siete partes iguales una parte dos
partes tres cuatro cinco seis
7 y listo acabamos de dividir cada uno
de estos lados en siete partes iguales
ahora sí esta cosa completa era igual a
esta cosa completa porque tenía su
símbolo de igual y dividimos en siete
partes iguales de los dos lados entonces
cada uno de estos pedacitos va a ser
igual a uno de los pedazos por acá ok
este pedazo es exactamente igual a este
pedazo y este otro pedazo va a ser
exactamente igual a este otro pedazo
igual este pedazo es igual a este pedazo
este otro pedazo es igual a este pedazo
y así nos seguimos con todos los pedazos
y entonces lo que acabamos concluyendo
es que cualquiera de los pedazos de acá
o sea por ejemplo este que es un
x que es igualita a todos los demás es
igual a cualquiera de los pedazos por
acá que son iguales y que son además dos
cositas entonces hemos concluido que x
es igual a 2 entonces vamos a hacer más
ejemplos para que se quede muy grabado
en tu cabeza que estamos tratando con
ecuaciones y que las ecuaciones las
podemos manipular como queramos para
encontrar a la equis pero cualquier cosa
que le hagamos a un lado del igual se lo
tenemos que hacer al otro lado también
aunque hay para hacer más ejercicios
vamos a necesitar más espacio así es que
déjame supuesto un poco y ahora vamos a
resolver 3x igual
15 ahora otra vez estoy segura de que
puedes resolver esta ecuación en tu
cabeza sustituyendo números hasta que
llegues a la respuesta correcta pero es
muy importante poder resolver esta
ecuación de una forma sistemática gay
aquí el chiste es transportar esta
ecuación hasta que nos quede la equis
solita okay queremos deshacernos de este
3 y bueno para hacer eso podemos dividir
entre 3 y porque queremos dividir entre
3 pues por que multiplicar por 3 y
después dividir entre 3 es como no
hacerle nada a la equis
ahora es muy importante recordar que
estamos en una ecuación y entonces si
tenemos que 3x es igual a 15 y quiero
dividir de este lado entre 3 para poder
seguir poniendo este símbolo de igual y
que tengamos todavía una ecuación lo que
tengo que hacer es dividir el lado
derecho también entre 3 y ahora si esta
cosa si sigue siendo igual a esta cosa
de acá bueno y entonces aquí lo que
tenemos es que 3 x x / x los 3 se
cancelan y nos queda simplemente una x
igual a 15 entre 3 15 y listo
x es igual a 5 ahora esta no es la única
forma de resolver esta ecuación entonces
vamos a ver otra forma tenemos aquí
x igual a
15 y tú no puedes decir eh y sal
yo conozco otra forma de deshacerme de
ese 3 porque no multiplicas por 1 entre
3 de los dos lados de la ecuación aunque
y entonces como estamos multiplicando
por lo mismo de los dos lados de la
ecuación entonces este lado sigue siendo
igual a este lado y entonces si tomamos
estos dos números y los multiplicamos
pues tenemos un tercio por tres de eso
lo que nos queda es 3 entre 3 que es
igual a 1 y esto está multiplicando a x
y es igual a 15 por un tercio pero 15
por un tercio es igual a 5 que entonces
aunque aquí la x no se vea completamente
solita ya está solita porque resulta que
uno x
x es exactamente igual a x así es que
listo tenemos que x es igual a 5
y bueno resulta que multiplicar por un
tercio es exactamente equivalente a
dividir entre 3
ahora vamos a resolver una ecuación
ligeramente más complicada aunque vamos
a ver dos de las cuatro e igual a 10 y 8
ok entonces para empezar la variable ya
no es x ahora es una y y segundo si
queremos sustituir por ejemplo ya
igualados para ver si ya igualados es la
respuesta correcta resulta que está un
poco más difícil no o sea tenemos 2 x 2
igual a 4 más 4 x 2 igual a 88 más 4 12
12 no es igual a 18 entonces ya
igualados no es la respuesta correcta
pero si te fijas ya nos tardamos un poco
más no o sea ahorita sustituyendo
valores de y está un poco más complicado
ver cuál es la respuesta no
pero bueno entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es ver qué es lo que nos está diciendo
esta ecuación aquí tenemos dos y esto lo
que significa es que estamos a una y
sumándole otra y y después aquí tenemos
más 4 o sea que tenemos que sumar otras
4 james 1 2 3 y 4 y eso todo esto es
igual a 18 es igual a 10 y 8 ahora
cuántas veces tengo por aquí pues tengo
1 2 3 4 5 6 10 aunque aquí todo esto
como estamos sumando el 6 es esto es
igual
6% entonces esta ecuación lo que es 6 es
igual a 18
6 que es igual a 18 lo cual tiene todo
el sentido del mundo no o sea porque
aquí tenemos 24 y 24 es 6 ok o sea si
tenemos dos manzanas y le sumamos cuatro
manzanas pues eso lo que nos queda es
simplemente seis manzanas y lo mismo
pasa con las variables a que hay dos
yemas cuatro y es igual a seis y ahora
con un poco de suerte ya sabemos
exactamente cómo resolver estas
ecuaciones aquí lo que hacemos es
dividir de los dos lados del igual entre
el coeficiente de nuestra variable g
y entonces este 6 se cancela con este 6
y nos queda que ya es igual a 18 entre 6
es igual a 3
los padres de las ecuaciones es que
siempre podemos checar que la respuesta
que nosotros estamos dando sea correcta
ok entonces aquí podemos checar que ya
en efecto si es igual a 3 sustituyendo
por 3 en nuestra ecuación original
aunque entonces lo que vamos a hacer es
fijarnos en la ecuación y en cada lugar
donde veamos un ayer vamos a poner un 3
y si lo que nos queda si es igual a 18
eso está comprobando que en efecto tiene
que ser igual a 3 entonces tenemos por
aquí dos por tres tres más cuatro por
tres y dos por tres
4 x 3 es 12 y 6 12 en efecto si es igual
a 18
entonces ya verificamos que jett si
tiene que ser igual a 3 y listo